arthur pendragon
regarde pas bien grand blond convaincu
il ya dix ans qu'on a plus vu son pif il
et cannelle fiston dragon c'est tous
évidemment qu'il est pas mort ça fait
dix ans que migros salsifis mon dieu par
tous les saints non non non non
commencés pas je suis absolument pas
royer pas besoin de se lever
à l'asl a retrouvé le jeu vous fait tous
pendre le palais partie pas bon alors ce
très constructif la résistance ça vous
dit quelque chose
lisez ça pouvait être intéressant
d'organiser une rencontre avec les
représentants de la résistance vous
entendez quelque chose et hâtive avec
une voix ton qui gagnent dire vous
entendez quelque chose pour faire
quelque chose de complètement informel
c'est pas possible d'être largué voilà
comment ça se passe cette petite
résistance
bon vous faites deux cent pas sur le
chemin et vous monter la garde au cas où
quelqu'un approche approche son chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous monter la garde et si la
personne qui approche suppose revient
non vous monter la garde
il y aurait moyen de réduire la voilure
sur la connerie
de fils pendragon est de retour en bas
qui viennent
il faut tuer arthur vous ne savez pas
faire ça entraîner les troupes
télésiège
le faisiez pas impensable
bah oui mais j'en prenais pas des
débiles si j'entre à des débiles mais
pas des débiles comme ça
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
pas vous êtes de retour dès fois que
vous redevenir roi quoi oui oui basse et
c'est vrai que ça fait envie quoi voir
maintenant si vous ne sentez pas vous le
sentez pas